welcome to Eldon ring I can't believe we
finally made it to the launch first
things first let's beat the tutorial
boss I mean I call it a tutorial boss
but this place isn't a tutorial you're
not going to learn much here I mean
you're gonna learn how to die and that's
about it this boss is tough plus the
reset for this area if you want to beat
this boss first try it just takes ages
so learning his moveset is a hassle and
you need to learn his moveset
so eat your boiled prawns and get ready
foreign
what's the reward for beating this boss
is it worth it I want to say yes it is
worth it especially if you want a
powerful weapon and a powerful shield
for the early game by watching this
video I think I can help you get them so
every boss has a tax you want to look
out for that was one of them it's very
exploitable and so is this
foreign if you see that attack winding
up then you'll have plenty of time to
mentally prepare for the Parry although
the Parry window is pretty tight as you
can see there so if you try this you're
going to want to choose a class with a
100 physical block Shield the Vagabond
and the Confessor both have one the
Vagabond has a lot more health and
better armor than the Confessor but the
Confessor has a heel which means there's
a little bit of room for error but the
best starting class for this encounter
anyway is definitely the samurai I mean
he comes with a long bow and a ton of
arrows and a really good Longbow weapon
art that just lets you destroy this boss
from range you don't even have to really
learn the intricacies of too many of his
attacks
thank you
so who is this boss the grafted Scion
the name alone is super poetic and it
tells us so much so grafting is a
Horticultural procedure whereby tissues
of plants are joined so they can
continue their growth together now
asayan is a young shoot or a twig of a
plant that is specifically chosen for
this purpose so this boss might have
been chosen for the purpose of grafting
but a Scion also has another double
meaning in that a Scion is a descendant
of a notable family and based on the
weapons this boss is wielding there's
definitely some nobility there the
description of his swords reads after
falling from Grace the dregs of the
golden lineage sought power and purpose
in the past I wonder if the process of
grafting was a part of this past and I
assume they're resorting to this
depraved act to get their power back
that was a good fight
man just the feeling of practicing and
overcoming difficulty is so rewarding
and it's absolutely there in Elden ring
some bosses are easy but some you really
have to learn everything about them and
that means there's something here for
every type of player I think
these swords should appeal to every
player they only require 14 dexterity
and 10 strength the shield on the other
hand requires 24.
so where do we go now well you walk
forward here and a great Crow carries
your way
or not
[Music]
so I'm skipping ahead here I've leveled
up my character a fair bit and I've
cleared pretty much all of the stuff
that was within the fog in the closed
Network test it's definitely time to
move on from that content we're headed
south
so the concept with this edited
playthrough is to have a really good 30
35 minute session with the game going
through a lot of really good story beats
and exciting gameplay encounters and
showing great things that you might have
missed and showing off tips everything
so this route that I'm taking through
the world it's really heavily planned
out but it has to be executed perfectly
in my eyes and I've actually attempted
this run multiple times by reloading my
saves
I was pretty happy with how this one
went
however just because I planned this out
doesn't mean I don't run into trouble
the game is still hard I will still fail
foreign
yeah so that attack is very cool you can
only use it when you charge up your
attack fully while the swords are buffed
though
so these soldiers that were fighting
they are soldiers of godric who resides
in stormvale Castle upon their tabbard
is a lion Crest and it's the same line
Crest that was upon the shield that we
got from killing the grafted Scion
according to that Shield the lion emblem
depicted is sarosh an aged counselor who
guides the golden lineage but the golden
lineage is clearly in disrepair and
these soldiers are not in complete
control of this area
hello
is somebody there might I bend your ear
for a moment please my name is Arena
I've escaped from castlemorne to the
South
servants there have rebelled I
I can't be sure what it is my eyesight's
been weak since birth you see but I
swear I heard frightful howling from all
over this poor woman was being escorted
out of Castle mourn probably via this
Carriage that lies destroyed in front of
us my good father secreted me out the
castle but decided himself to stay
he says it's his duty
as commander
we're fighting our way through the
dejected remains of Arena's Entourage
right there their bodies are being
Savaged by wild dogs and worse I I fear
for Father's life
servants are full Roth
filled with hatred for every one of us
they've since come for every one of the
companions I escaped with they haven't
spared a soul my fear it's no different
at Castle one please
I implore you would you mind taking a
letter to my father at the castle and my
soul wishes that he escaped even if his
honor should be the price
what's so amazing about that whole
sequence is just how well it tells the
story through the environment but also
how well it humanizes all of the enemies
we just faced that doesn't happen very
often in Souls games but it adds so much
to the world you know those beastly
creatures were former Servants of Castle
mourn which we're heading to now and
those soldiers of godric those were
simple soldiers enlisted to defend a
noble on her Escape out of the castle
the giant was pulling the ruined
Carriage the dogs were feasting upon
their corpses there was a story there if
you're paying attention to it
right now I'm prepping for what is
probably the most difficult encounter in
this run it's a boss fight that only
shows up at night against the night
Cavalry one of those riders that was
featured in a previous story cut scene
where they were talking about the Rune
of death being stolen
I want that weapon I want that weapon so
bad it just suits the sort of dark
Templar Confessor character that I'm
going for so we need every Advantage we
need kukri we need to sneak up on him we
need to use fire weapons and I'm gonna
use a flail myself because the flail
does bleed damage and if I can bleed him
out then that will be really good
because bleed is a percentage and that's
usually better against encounters that
you're under level for
also the flail is just cool as hell
especially when it's imbued with fire
the best strategy while you're mounted
against this guy is to try to stay
behind him and it's worth remembering
that you can quickly change directions
while doing mounted combat by doing a
double jump
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
flasks not looking too good so I try to
pull out the cookery because I forgot to
equip them I desperately want to bleed
this guy or kill his horse so I can even
the odds you'll be surprised how much
damage you can do when he's off the
horse
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
this is where you get your damage in but
I am aware I'm one hit away from death
and if I let this go too long he does a
mounting up attack that does quick AOE
damage
so I decided to keep my distance
[Music]
foreign
and the rewards from this boss are so
good barricade Shield which you'll
remember from some of my earlier
playthroughs in the network test and the
Knight Riders flail
24 decks requirement that's why I have
like no Health but I do decent damage
now at least
after I'm done applying the ashes of War
it's time to go to Round Table hold this
is a place that you'll unlock after
defeating Margaret as melaner invites
you there
forgive me
I've been
testing you to see whether or not Grace
truly does guide you and
whether you are fit to face the
challenge that entails it seems my
worries were unfounded torrent had your
measure from the very start
whereas I merely pretended there is but
one other thing I can do to offer you
guidance I can take you to the round
table Hall Gathering Place
of tarnished champions
Guided by grace
the last time a new tarnished made their
way to the round table very well
as your senior
I bet you welcome it is safe here
you may let down your guard
allow me a word of advice as your senior
you had a mere visitor to the round
table nothing more a house guest
here to earn their keep remember your
place
newcomer
nice to have this dialogue play as we go
deeper into the Roundtable hold with our
stone sword Keys the senior has more to
say later on oh
are you aggrieved at the notion knew
about a visit and here then you would do
well to remember the first words of
Grace given to you stand before the
Elden ring and become the Elden Lord if
those words held any meaning to you
follow the guidance of Grace
lay low The Shard bearers
and claim for yourself
a great Rune do so and the doors to the
round tables in the chamber will open
and you will receive the wisdom of the
two fingers once the wisdom of the two
fingers becomes your own I'll impart to
you a proper welcome as a true member of
the Round Table
oh I see you've just arrived welcome to
the round table hold
I'm Corin a man of the cloth I teach
incantations the strength granted Us by
the two fingers and explore the secrets
of the golden order so that one day if a
tarnished of the Round Table hold should
become Elden Lord
I might counsel them ensuring order
regains its proper form writing rule
over Men by the way
still see it
the guidance of Grace
you do
wonderful news most tarnished are blind
to it these days you are something of a
rare breed well
what do you say care to learn an
incantation of the two fingers
that is a work of heresy its
incantations bear no lineage from the
earth tree
very well
I'll take it off your hands darkness is
a spell that we use a little bit later
on it's an incantation of the two
fingers servants who once served as the
Assassins of the Round Table hold May
the golden order shine through you
these assassins were themselves once
tarnished who had strayed from guidance
and they pursued their Duty in the
darkness that is without Grace maybe
this played a part in our Exile your new
face
no matter it's all the same
loud your arms
let's get smithing
as Eve noticed the chains nothing
special
I'm a prisoner and these are my chains
I'm trapped by the hole
undying smithing for you fools
I love the atmosphere in this place the
round table hold itself almost feels
like a character by way of example the
blacksmith just claimed that the round
table hold itself chains him
greetings great Champion called by Grace
I am fear circumstances have compelled
my stay at the round table hope great
champion
would you allow me to hold you
but briefly perhaps you might share with
me some of your Lively vigor
and your stout-heartedness doing so will
grant me the warmth of a champion and
you I am sure will bear a boulderkin's
blessing so that's fear the deathbed
companion that was mentioned in the
opening cinematic she's one of the
famous tarnished and I wonder what's
making her stay at the round table hold
one thing to bear in mind is that I
haven't played that much of the game yet
I don't have the answers I've had access
for a couple of days and in that time
I've made sure to only really comb
through the early areas as much as I can
as of the time of recording Eldon ring
is about to release in an hour but
reviewers have had the game for a while
and man the response is insane a lot of
Metacritic sites are having it hailed as
one of the best games of all time if not
the best by a lot of their metrics from
the biggest details to the smallest like
that Forest Watchtower shooting a
demi-human they've just done such an
amazing job at crafting unique
encounters to cram into this world and
it might well be a masterpiece I know
I'm always pretty positive on from
software stuff but it's just a privilege
to be able to talk about this and bring
it to you all I hope I can do it justice
you know that's the goal
one interesting encounter is with these
Candlestick Phantoms that lead you to
points of interest I look at where this
one's going and I realize there's a
little ledge underneath me that I can
jump down to
this leads to the earth ball cave
I think the name is implying that
something has borrowed into this place
there's so much to explore I kind of
forgot we're supposed to be on a quest
to reach irina's father
so easy to get distracted
gotta explore the cave though I mean
look at that chest over there
foreign
nice of those two rats behind me not to
join in
foreign
I like that they give you kukri here
it's a bit of a hint I think that the
next boss is a bit weak to bleed attacks
which is usually the case for most
beastly creatures bleed and fire that's
the way to go
uh for some reason he doesn't aggro here
I take this chance to get my sleep
potions ready I didn't realize they need
FP to throw sleep has been nerfed a lot
since the network test but it's still
pretty good against the bear although
they do need to stand in that cloud for
it to take effect
the Bear's asleep now I decided to do a
charge tattoo attack here because with a
lot of bosses you can do a charge to R2
attack and still get the critical
afterwards not with this boss though
apparently
foreign
I'ma head out
it's a bit of a bore that cave
so again as of the recording of this
video it's now 2 A.M here and Eldon ring
has officially launched
it's an awkward place to be in as a
Creator because all I want to do is just
play through this game completely and
not think about content at all but at
the same time I have to think about the
content it's my job and it's something
that I enjoy I enjoy bringing this game
to you all through my videos and that is
part of the enjoyment I get out of a
game release you know it's not just
playing the game for me it's creating
content about it
that said
I get this fear of missing out you know
what I mean like I've just been hearing
fellow reviewers talking and venting
about how amazing this game is and I am
only in the early stages of the game and
a part of me just wants to catch up and
rush through it but I have to stop
myself thinking that way you know like
fear of missing out is an awful feeling
and I just want to take my time with
this game and really really savor it and
I think that's something we should all
remember like don't just rush to the end
of this game don't just rush through it
they've spent so long crafting
experiences and you should do your best
to take your time
in a recent video we talked a lot about
what these enemies are doing they're
unleashing the flame of frenzy from
their eyes the flame of frenzy is
essentially like a sort of Eldritch
truth
it's something they've seen that is
driving them mad and the crazy thing
about it is that it can affect rats as
well they infest this church of America
that we're coming up on now
this is actually where you get the flame
of frenzy spell
foreign
I'll be honest I died on purpose here no
I actually I have merch about that
animation so I kind of needed to work it
in somehow this incredible piece of
artwork inspired by the flame of frenzy
was worked on by Chun Lo who does an
amazing job with all my Teespring
designs so if you need a hoodie or a
shirt or if you just want to support
what I'm doing on the channel then check
it out
finally in the distance is Castle mourn
the place that Arena wants us to visit
to find her father
a funny thing about mourn and Arena
those two names are very heavily
featured in Dark Souls 3. Arena was a
blind faith character in that and mourn
was her Kareem companion she was in
training to become a fire keeper and she
was Inseparable from him
funny that they reuse similar Concepts
like that
foreign
giant here
you have to start piecing together all
of the allegiances of different enemies
in this game and right now I'm starting
to think those Giants are on the side of
godric
they are fighting to defend Castle mourn
and the warden of Castle mourn was
appointed by godric although Castle
mourn has been lost or at least it's in
the process of being lost as you'll see
you'll recall back at Arena whose
Carriage was destroyed by the
ex-servants of mourn Castle
those creatures were so beastly and you
have to wonder if a transformation has
taken place although considering the
demi-humans maybe this is just a race of
beings that is abused or taken advantage
of
and like the demi-humans they're
probably tired of it
so this fight is going pretty poorly
when you do six rolls in a row like that
that's how you know
good thing I have my get out of jail
free card
Darkness
that God counter comes out fast on the
flail every weapon has a different guard
counter animation you want something
that comes out quickly and do you want
something that does a sort of horizontal
sweep in my experience
got the flail and barricade Shield are
just a deadly combo you take like no
damage while blocking you do a quick
guard counter to follow up and you get
the flail and the ash of war from the
same boss which is cool that said I'm
the kind of person who has trouble
sticking to one weapon this game just
throws so many incredible options at you
how are you supposed to stick to just
one
but I think I'm gonna make that a bit of
a staple of this series if it continues
I think I'm gonna make a different build
every time and just show off a different
way to play and where to get the key
items for different builds
[Music]
man I was gonna have a sick role play
here where I like sneak through using
assassin's approach while they all fight
that arrow in my head's kind of ruining
the seriousness of this scene
oh it's gone
I love that the enemies are fighting
each other there's just so much drama
going on in this sequence of exploring
the castle
uh there's a face I've not seen before I
met your Warden of this Castle as
ordained by Lord godwig himself but you
can see how things have turned out
the menials have all rebelled they gave
me good service or so I thought
but it seems it was all an act
foul creatures as it said and true
enough their foul inside and out
I'm sorry to disappoint you but whatever
you come here to do I'm afraid Castle
mourn won't hold much longer of course
this is Arena's father and you can give
him her letter I see from Arena thank
you
I'm in your debt but I can't leave yet
even if the castle should fall as
Commander I must remain to ensure the
treasured sword and mourn does not fall
into the wrong hands
the legendary sword of Castle mourn is
the grafted blade Greatsword this
storied sword is a revenger's weapon
I'll explain more when I find it but
it's important to note at this stage
that the story of Castle mourn is one
that is mired in themes of Vengeance and
revenge
these themes played a part in the
ancient past of Castle mourn which we'll
talk about in a moment but these themes
of Revenge are playing out in the
present as well against the nobility
fascinating that that Noble is more
afraid of being eaten and the disgrace
that that would cause him than he is of
death itself maybe death isn't as big of
a thing in the lands between or maybe an
ability and being Noble is really
important
if you see Arena do tell her her father
will come for her once he's fulfilled
his duties
According to some law that is written
upon great swords that are outside
Castle mourn long ago this place was
under siege and in this Siege A Lone
Hero fought for his Vengeance only to
fall at the hand of Lord Godfrey
again this reinforces the Vengeance
theme that is all over that legendary
sword that we mentioned earlier
honestly I'm kind of going out of my way
to use the darkness spell and make it
seem useful but in reality I'm a bit
doubtful about this one although maybe
it's supposed to be used offensively
instead of defensively because while
enemies are blinded they are very very
easy to backstab
so in this upcoming boss I use my spirit
summons for the first time and I think
it's my kind of informal rule that I'll
use Spirit summons if I'm having a lot
of trouble with a boss or maybe if it's
like a main boss kind of thing
in general though I've noticed Spirit
summons can make some encounters
ridiculously easy
although some bosses are also absurdly
difficult
[Music]
this boss isn't that bad by the way
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
counters here
foreign
I should probably also level vigor
in my next fight with this boss I decide
to use the boulderkin's blessing which
is the blessing we got from Fear the
deathbed companion these blessings are a
powerful buff that consumes FP and also
they use up some of your maximum health
while you have them in your inventory so
it's best to find an opportunity for
them as soon as possible you
very warm
what you felt light up inside you was a
bulldogan's blessing oh it is but a
fleeting thing I am afraid come
should you require another I will take
you in my arms
as often as you need this boulderkin's
blessing increases your Poise which is
admittedly not very good against a boss
that can one shot you but hey at least
it gave me a little bit of my health
back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
so we recover this sword of Vengeance
and return it to Edgar I'm in your debt
for keeping the sword from those Fallen
creatures are no longer bound by Duty
unsafe rescued Arena I will spend my
remaining days with her
greener
how could this be my daughter deserved
better
the [ __ ] life with me
I chose Duty over my daughter's safety
and that is how Fate has answered
I'll find him the foul wretched
responsible for this I'll hunt them down
and exterminate every last one of them
rest assured Arena it will be done
and so the cycle of Vengeance continues
thank you for watching this very long
video leave a like if you enjoyed it
consider getting the merch that I
mentioned earlier and I'm so excited
that everyone can play the game now and
have Adventures that I just like this
one